I think what is that saying 70 of us
will be affected by but I think it's
probably higher it's just lack of
awareness sometimes four different types
of imposters that we can kind of
experience the first one is the natural
genius so this is I need to get things
right first time around and if I don't
it's not because it's a new task or
something difficult it's because I'm not
good enough you've then got the expert
which is I need to know all the answers
I never know enough the third one is the
workaholic so this is where you believe
I'm never going to be as talented or as
knowledgeable as anyone else around me
so I'm always gonna have to work two or
three times harder fourth one is the
most common one which is the
perfectionist but it's reframing that
imposter syndrome and again similar to
your thoughts is looking at the benefits
like if you think back to every time
your imposter has showed up you think
back to every challenge you've had to
overcome your imposter has been there
you feel sort of empowered every time
you've overcome a challenge in your life